Harry I only have one thing to say to
you you're a naughty little possum what
is a naughty possum Harry um I actually
don't know like I actually genuinely
don't know what I say sometimes like I
just came in so hot and heavy and ours I
know another possums eye who shows that
this idiot did you say that before the
show or did the retreat bring that out
of you I've said it a couple of times to
my friends like when I'm you know I had
a couple too many drinks but as soon as
I was there's just like the most nervous
and weird side of me just wanted to show
up and Abbey and Harry you are so
charming and wonderful I we all are
gonna fall in love with you I think
watching this show how do you feel
people will react are you nervous are
you excited are you scared for any
moments people might see from you on
camera I know I am a bit of because I
just came in so hot and heavy and I
didn't realize that what we didn't get
told the rules until as you know like my
reaction and yeah so I'm a little bit
nervous before that point and then I
guess once I start following my heart
and going deeper into it I'm excited to
see that I'm probably experience those
feelings again and then just watch
myself become like a big tub of melted
butter this gorgeous woman you kind of
just gave a little smile again they're
talking about her so I will ask are you
and Francesca together now we're
actually talking about side about
getting married so I could go across the
border and see yeah so you two are very
much a couple when I get we got matching
tattoos why am i ting bold very modern
that's an exclusive I wouldn't visit her
when I was it when I was in Ottawa
go see her family and it was something
that we wanted to get for a while but
apparently Francesca across my neck
isn't a good idea so we went with the
Lightning mohawk you didn't want to post
Malone it okay it was just because it's
good like for both of us we have like a
bond it was like a lot of negativity
around our relationship and it kind of
like made his tour together a little bit
more and I guess on the show like every
time I was with those I look like let's
just stay positive let's stay with
positive people and they keep that
positive mindset because that's what's
gonna get us through like let's not
focus on people making us feel like
idiots but trying to pull our hearts so
I kind of just it's kind of like off
that which is a little bit sad but like
it's just a nice little reminder to stay
positive it just stay with Francesca
stay with Reggie okay so how in love are
you is this woman the love of your life
so we actually broke up for a few months
in between so after the show everything
was like just like a roller coaster like
it was straight up and just heightened
emotions and then we had a couple months
and then we took a break and then you
know a few months ago I accidentally got
drunk in LA and texted her that I wanted
to FaceTime her dog I was I hate I don't
want to talk to you can I just talk to
you puppy um which in turn it turns out
dogs don't have fingers so they can't
open a FaceTime call from a drunk guy
3:00 a.m. so at that point I was we just
started talking and I was like hey look
I don't want to watch myself fall in
love with you being this like having
this many questions and no answers and
she's like people why don't we just see
each other that kind of caught so much I
want to say to you and hey long story
short fluid down fell in love again now
we want to get married and the ring
bearer will be a possum why did you guys
break up
um I think like everybody I know at that
point I didn't do it for a month and I
only knew like one side of Francesca
challenging deck one side
outside of the show like we have
completely different lives she's got a
whole bunch of annoying friends and not
anymore but it was just crazy
so it was like a information overload
that coming off this shot and they we
didn't really know each other well
enough to like trust each other
especially living in Auckland New
Zealand and she was in Vancouver but we
were visiting each other every two weeks
but I just got to a point where we both
just needed I think it was the best
thing we did it just took a step back
because right now we just cherish each
other so much more like we dated a few
people in between both of us and like I
even it sucks five and said to the the
last guy then it I was like hey look
like I'm still madly in love with my ex
and I'm so sorry but we can't do this
horrible person I know but at least I
was honest three how old are you I'm 22
so what need to okay well here's what I
think is I'm just gonna give it to you
straight Harry it's like on the one hand
you near this charming cute guy with an
accent and you're only 22 but on the
other hand you're saying you're in love
with this woman and you're you would
want to marry her so where do you think
this is gonna end up would you propose
tomorrow oh yeah okay so my goal is with
the winnings we've gotta fight at Paris
and I was gonna surprise her propose but
then obviously we can't do anything in
that now and I accidentally told her
yesterday that was my plan from day one
and I was like well I thought you knew
but turns out I'd never told it which I
shouldn't know so yeah like I
legitimately like I'm only like I'm so
much more happier when I'm around and
when I have a presence around me and
like having her in my life sorry yeah I
could right now like wow do you think
you're ready for marriage no definitely
not but if I'm not ready for anything so
are you gonna wait a bit on proposing or
no just dive in um it's like obviously
off the quarantine
it's probably gonna be a few months I at
that point I'll be just completely
driven up the wall sorry when I see it
I'll be wanting to put babies in it and
I we want to marry you and get ready to
retire like that's probably how intense
but at this point happy just taking
alone see what happens wow there's a
real irony in this you went on a show
where you were told you couldn't have
sex and you had to stay in a house and
now you are again locked in a house and
you can't have sex when the show is
gonna air it's kind of crazy it is like
like I don't know what the universe is
telling me but maybe you know it's
telling me I need to just put it away
for for a few months be born-again
virgin arrey your face
I think fell the most of anybody's when
Lana revealed the news I mean you look
crushed what was going through your mind
when you heard that after you had just
met Francesca the most gorgeous woman
ever I had like you couldn't have done a
worse thing to me at that point in time
like I legitimately I thinking about it
makes me want to cry because it was like
I have got the most gorgeous girl I've
ever seen in my entire life
and there's literally nothing I want to
do fight back you know haven't like
enjoy each other and then they drop
these rules on us I remember like I I
was like the French I was like we're
making a pact we're gonna spend all that
money who cares about anyone else like I
was crying I was so angry and aggressive
and I remember like one of the producers
pulled me inside like how are you you're
not going anywhere really like relax
like why look just calm down it because
I was like I'm leaving like why would
you put me here I'm leaving I can't deal
with this and they relax you need to
understand that this is what's gonna
help you I don't know what I need to
stop arguing and just start listening
and following my heart and it was the
best thing I did is something about
something with that head are you at all
nervous to watch any parts of the show
back my big lie an episode
- I know are you doing I was watching it
like what's this guy doing he has the
most gorgeous woman here he she's into
him and he just made up a lie and threw
her under the bus why did you do that no
I liked her right so why did you say she
kissed you why did you lie
actually I don't know I into other women
at that point or was it all Francesca oh
I knew as soon as I sort of like I
couldn't like I couldn't try anyone like
I couldn't even look at just yeah so
what is it gonna be like for you guys's
relationship to watch this back um I
know that there's gonna be some testing
things for me personally like watching
the Kells date that she has and I hope
you're showing him because obviously
it's only you know you guys only see
like a small snippet of it but there was
so much more that went on and then the
gory date and stuff like that like
that's I remember that just being so
distressed and angry at that stuff and I
think I still hold a little bit of anger
because you know like I was mad I was
Maggie that was me I am madly in love
with Francesca and seeing all that stuff
happen kind of like told me apart but
then again I can't get mad about it
because I was a bit I was being a bit of
a dick and we're in a way better spot
now you know for me to get angry about
something of the past is completely
immature and stupid
[Music]